[Music]
water water is something that most of us
take for granted I live in Los Angeles
it's essentially a desert never once
have I thought twice about my unlimited
access to this one thing that we all
need to live and to thrive but this is
not the reality for so many people all
across the world in fact 663 million
people across planet Earth don't have
access to clean water in a couple weeks
on October 20 I turned 51 I don't need
any presents I want for nothing with one
exception I need your help I've decided
to partner with charity water to raise
funds to contribute to clean water
projects for those most in need I've set
a goal of 51 thousand dollars and if we
meet that goal we will be able to
provide clean water for over 1,500
people not only will this provide clean
water access for this group of people
for the first time in their lives
it will provide clean water for
generations to come and the ripple
effect the impact of that is just so
profound and basically priceless so I
need your help to get there I'm asking
that everybody who is watching this
contribute one dollar for every year
that I've been drinking clean water on
planet Earth it's easy to feel
disenfranchised in today's world we have
huge problems but this is one we can
actually solve together we are so
powerful together we really can change
the world to find out more in to donate
visit my fundraising page at my charity
water.org forward slash rich roll or
click on the link in the description
below